people they're looking for a explanation
and people say well as artists you don't
have to give an explanation but as a
leader you do so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
obvious thing
shortly after Kanye West made headlines
for wearing a white lives matter shirt
at Paris fashion week he's back in the
hot seat this time for sharing several
posts that were deemed anti-semitic I'm
just extremely happy can you tell by my
face
on Sunday the Grammy winner wrote on
Instagram that he planned to go Defcon 3
on Jewish people a comment that got his
Instagram account restricted and
post-deleted and yay wasn't feeling it
logging onto Twitter to post for the
first time in two years claiming he's
not anti-semitic and calling out
Instagram boss Mark Zuckerberg those
posts were also later removed from
Twitter due to a violation of the
platform's policies now Kanye's accounts
are still active but he can't post or
comment for an undisclosed amount of
time and his latest controversy has
celebs speaking out Jamie Lee Curtis
tweeted words matter and added a public
plea to the father of four quote your
words hurt and incite violence you are a
father please stop Sarah Silverman noted
that Kanye's threat to the Jewish
population wasn't trending on Twitter
quote the silence is so loud
John Legend a former friend of yays
called him out without naming names
tweeting quote weird how all these free
independent thinkers always land at the
same old anti-blackness and
anti-Semitism meanwhile Jack Antonoff
was a little more blunt and to the point
quote Kanye a little [ __ ] yeah I'm just
gonna go with that of course this all
comes after the fashion designer enraged
social media for sporting a white lives
matter shirt at his Yeezy season 9
presentation he doubled down on the
messaging during a sit-down on Fox
news's Tucker Carlson tonight my dad is
a educated
um ex-black Panther
and he put a text to me today he said
White lives matter
and I said I thought the shirt was
a funny shirt I thought the idea of me
wearing it was funny and I said dad what
do you think it was funny he said just
a black man stating the obvious White
lives matter has been classified by the
Anti-Defamation League as a white
supremacist phrase that originated in
2015 following the start of the black
lives matter Movement we are in a battle
with the media like the majority of the
media has a Godless agenda and
their jokes are not working this whole
like oh yeah he's crazy and all these
things they don't work several
severals walked out of the Yeezy show
later explaining on Twitter quote I
don't care who it is if I don't support
the message I'm out pretty much is what
I'm saying with that Jamil Hill tweeted
that the shirt sends a dangerously dumb
message and Van Lathan called the move
frustrating emotionally draining and the
whole problem
foreign